- This episode of LegalEagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking on the link
in the description.
Unidentified federal officers
wearing full camouflage,
jumping out of unmarked vehicles,
picking up seemingly random protestors,
handcuffing them, and then speeding away.
This isn't George Orwell's "1984."
This is America, 2020, Portland, Oregon.
There have been over 50 straight days
of protests in Portland, Oregon,
sparked by the murders of George Floyd,
Breonna Taylor, and other
citizens killed by police.
These protests have been mostly peaceful,
but a few people have committed
acts of vandalism and property damage.
But back in June,
President Trump activated
at least a dozen different
law enforcement agencies
to "restore order" during
protests in Washington, DC.
- Thousands and thousands
of heavily-armed soldiers.
- At the time, the federal government
justified this show of force
with vague references to
DC's status as not a state,
but the show of force
actually had little to do
with DC's precarious legal status.
Instead, the response in
DC was more like a dry run,
a first attempt at using
federal police to stop protests.
Now, more than a hundred
law enforcement officers
have been deployed to Portland, Oregon,
and many of those officers
are not identifying themselves verbally
or through insignia on their uniforms.
They're driving around in vehicles
not marked as law enforcement.
And they refuse to say who they are,
even to those that they arrest.
They have apparently kidnapped
protesters off the street
and taken them to jail cells.
They've gone on the offensive
and they've shot protesters
with kinetic impact munitions.
Federal officers have also
sprayed tear gas at protesters,
prompting Oregon moms
to form a human shield
to protect people who were
peacefully protesting.
They've attacked a Navy veteran
who came to ask officers
whether they understood the oath
that they took to the US Constitution,
who just didn't respond
like an absolute boss.
All of this happened without the approval
of Oregon state officials.
All in all, this is a
chilling show of force
in an allegedly free society.
Are we witnessing military
detention of protestors?
Does the federal government
have authority to do this?
And do protesters have
the right to fight back
and stand their ground against people
who are not clearly
identified as law enforcement?
And most importantly, how
worried should we all be?
(reverent orchestral music)
Hey, LegalEagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because there are reports of protestors
in Portland, Oregon being disappeared
by federal law enforcement
potentially operating
outside of its jurisdictional limits.
Now, in this episode,
we're going to explain
what the heck is going on in Portland.
And if you're upset
about what's happening,
you're not alone.
In fact, Oregon has already filed suit
against the federal government
to stop these tactics.
But let's begin at the beginning
with the jurisdiction of
federal law enforcement officers
operating in the states.
The basic questions are which
law enforcement agencies
have authority over
federal land and property
and under what circumstances
can federal law enforcement
go beyond just federal land
and operate within the
jurisdiction of the state?
Now, Congress has the authority
to create law enforcement organizations
to patrol and protect
areas of federal property.
Violations occurring
within the federal land
will then be handled by federal
law enforcement officers.
For example, the Bureau of Land
Management has the authority
to undertake traditional
police activities on BLM,
the other BLM, lands, which
include national parks,
but they cannot make
arrests under state laws
unless they have written authorization
by state or local officials.
According to an opinion by
the Office of Legal Counsel
in 2012, federal enforcement personnel
lack the authority to make
arrests under state law.
And remember, state law is generally
the one that we think of
when we think of general
criminal activities,
the stuff that police
often arrest people under,
unless that authority is expressly granted
by either federal or state law
and the federal officers'
exercise of authority
complies with the Purpose Act,
which requires that federal funds be used
only for the purposes for
which they were appropriated.
By the way, I am deeply
indebted to law professor
and Lawfare contributor
Steve Vladeck on this.
He's on Twitter at @steve_vladeck.
His research saved me a ton
of time putting this together
and you should really follow him
if you're into national security law.
So, which law enforcement agencies
are active in situations like this?
Well, the law enforcement
response in Washington, DC
involved many different
agencies and the National Guard.
And by most accounts,
the DC response was coordinated
by Attorney General Barr.
Barr has legal authority
to coordinate law enforcement officers
who are under the jurisdiction
of the Department of Justice,
like the FBI and the
Federal Bureau of Prisons.
In contrast, the federal
officers who are in Portland
appear to be from the Customs
and Border Protection.
CBP is under the jurisdiction
of the Department of Homeland Security.
So, let's talk about the
CBP's authority in Portland.
Does it have legal authority
to operate in Portland?
Well, yes, it probably does.
The Fourth Amendment of the
Constitution protects Americans
from random and arbitrary
stops and searches.
However, these basic
constitutional principles
do not apply fully at the "borders."
At border crossings,
including the ports of entry by the sea,
federal authorities do not need a warrant
or even suspicion of wrongdoing
to justify conducting
what the courts have
called a "routine search,"
such as searching luggage or a vehicle.
The federal officers cannot
suspend the US Constitution,
but the Supreme Court has given them
more leeway in these activities.
Federal regulations approved
by the Supreme Court,
give the CBP authority to operate
within 100 miles of any
US "external boundary."
The closest international
border to Portland
is the Pacific Ocean, and the ocean
is less than a hundred
miles away from Portland,
which gives the CBP
specific enforcement powers.
This relaxation of
constitutional protections
within a hundred miles
of any external border
and/or an ocean has
received a lotta criticism
from civil libertarians,
which correctly point out
that the vast majority of Americans
live within a hundred miles
of an external border.
Although CBP has legal authority
to enforce federal laws in Portland,
they cannot enforce state laws.
For example, CBP must
have reasonable suspicion
of an immigration violation
or violation of federal law
in order to pull someone
over and to stop them.
But, of course, not surprisingly,
the federal government does have authority
to protect federal property
and to investigate offenses
against that federal
property and federal land.
And generally, the federal agency
that's tasked with
protecting federal property
is the Federal Protective
Service, not the CBP.
But here, and perhaps in the future,
Customs and Border Patrol
is being authorized
under 40 USC 1315,
which allows the Department
of Homeland Security secretary
to designate other DHS officers
to backstop the Federal
Protective Service.
Section 1315, which was
enacted over a decade ago,
empowers the Department
of Homeland Security
to "make arrests without a warrant
"for any offense against the United States
"committed in the presence
of the officer or agent
"or for any felony
cognizable under the laws
"of the United States
if the officer or agent
"has reasonable grounds to believe
"that the person to be
arrested has committed
"or is committing a felony."
And under this section,
unless the federal officer
personally witnesses a
federal crime being committed
or has a reason to believe
an individual committed a federal offense,
the only authority under Section 1315
is to investigate offenses
against federal property,
which, again, is generally the purview
of the Federal Protective Services.
And, really here, the $64,000 question
is, "What qualifies as an investigation
"of an offense against federal property?"
But regardless of the
authorization of these regulations,
they're still limited by the Constitution.
In order to be able to
physically stop someone,
you need reasonable suspicion.
And according to the Supreme Court,
in order to put someone in
a van and drive them away,
you have to have probable cause.
And here, there are reports,
admittedly one-sided reports
coming from the protesters themselves,
that it doesn't seem
like the federal officers
have those kind of justifications.
And it also appears that
the federal officers
are operating pretty far away
from the federal property
that they've been tasked to protect
and potentially to
investigate crimes related to.
- [Ken] Well, we're 49 straight days
into violence and destruction in Portland,
so it justifies the response
because violence and destruction continue.
- Now, that's not to say
that the protests in Portland
have been entirely nonviolent.
It can be the case, as
it appears to be here,
that there can be some
people who are out rioting
and committing acts of
violence and vandalism
while the vast majority of
people are peacefully protesting.
And the thing about that
is that even if simple acts of vandalism
did justify the use of force,
and query whether that's true or not,
that doesn't justify using force
against the overwhelmingly
peaceful protestors of Portland
and lots of other American cities.
- [Ken] This is a posture
we intend to continue,
not just in Portland, but
in any of the facilities
that we're responsible
for around the country.
- America's not under siege by protestors.
And there's a concept
in the First Amendment
called the heckler's veto,
that you are not allowed
to use the violent reaction
of a minority to quell the
speech activity of the majority.
That's a heckler's veto,
and we don't want that.
But you don't have to take my word for it.
Let's kick it over to our
correspondent in the field,
a Portland resident and
a mom in the mom wall,
and my sister, Lil' Leg'l Eag'l.
- [Sister] LegalEagle,
we are here on a weekday.
It's about 9:45 p.m.
(protestors clapping)
And as you can hear,
we're singing dorky songs
and the moms and dads
are out in the thousands.
(crowd cheering)
It feels very safe actually right now.
So, even though everybody
has come prepared
with tear gas accoutrements,
some goggles, some helmets,
people are passing out water,
so far it has felt very peaceful
and everybody is singing
and getting along very well,
so it's been a really
wonderful experience so far.
♪ Hands up, please don't shoot me ♪
- The crowd has so far been very peaceful.
So, how this all started is a protest
for Black Lives Matter,
of course, spun off by the
murder of George Floyd.
And since then, here in
the past three nights,
there have been thousands of mom
that have shown up to
create a wall of moms.
So, the idea here is that
all of us are in yellow.
The dads are out tonight
as well in orange.
And the theme is that
we're protecting the youth
that are indiscriminately
and illegally being abducted,
beaten, any number of things by the feds
that have come into our city.
So, so far the night has
been absolutely lovely.
It's a warm, balmy evening.
People have been passing out
(toy squeaking)
these little pig squeakers,
which has been kind of delightful,
very Portland of the city.
And otherwise, we've been singing.
There have been people
of color representing
and speaking up on stage
and a lot of chants,
so it's been a really nice night.
- Thanks, Little Sis.
Really truly terrifying stuff.
I haven't seen that kind of carnage
since the Women's March of '17.
Stay safe out there and
don't get a paper cut
on all those signs.
- [All] Feds stay clear!
The moms are here!
- So, the next question,
naturally, is what federal laws
are CBP officers trying
to enforce in Portland?
Unlike Washington, DC,
where there's quite a
lot of federal property,
Oregon really doesn't
have that much property
that's under the exclusive jurisdiction
of the federal government.
Federal law enforcement
officers can arrest someone
who vandalizes a federal
building like a courthouse,
which there are some in downtown Portland,
and federal immigration
authorities can arrest people
for suspicion of
violating immigration laws
and for violating any federal law,
provided the federal offense happened
in the officer's presence.
But federal law enforcement officers
don't have the authority
to enforce state laws
on non-federal property.
And when you're talking about vandalism
of non-federal property,
that would clearly be a state-based law.
And here, the governor of Oregon
does not want federal law
enforcement in her state.
That leaves us with a
complicated situation
that's susceptible to abuse by
overzealous federal officers.
So, are federal officers simply protecting
federal courthouses from
vandalism in Portland?
It definitely doesn't look that way.
Reports suggest that CBP
officers are roaming the streets
a considerable distance
from federal property.
For example, protestor Mark Pettibone
was suddenly seized by camo-clad people
and thrown into an unmarked minivan.
Pettibone was taken to a
cell in a federal courthouse
where he was asked if he
would waive his rights.
He answered, "No," and was
then apparently released.
Pettibone wasn't charged with a crime.
He says that the men who grabbed him
did not identify themselves.
CBP said that Pettibone and
others who were detained
were wanted for destruction
of federal property
or assault on federal officers,
but there's been no proof of
these allegations yet though.
And the fact that these
people are being detained,
thrown in a cell, and then
released without charges,
makes these arrests seem pretty dubious.
CBP denies that its
officers are not identified.
The agency told reporters
that their uniforms have a CBP patch,
but officers are not identified by name
because they might be doxxed,
which might put their lives in danger.
This might strike some of
you as an acceptable reason
not to identify officers by name,
but note that even Army
soldiers in Iraq and Afghanistan
wear names on their uniforms,
both in English and Arabic.
Is the average Portland protestor
a greater menace than ISIS or Al-Qaeda?
And by the way, if you
want a great breakdown
between the differences
between police tactics and Army tactics,
check out my friend
Knowing Better's channel,
where he talks about his experience
serving in the military in Afghanistan
and the differences
between military and police
and the overlap between the two as well.
Legal commentator Ken
White probably put it best:
"Federalism, except for occupying cities
"and beating and detaining people
"on suspicion of vandalism."
So, now we get to the heart of the matter.
Did federal LEOs violate the law?
Well, let's talk about the
lack of identification.
Why is it bad for law enforcement
to go around without identification?
Well, first and foremost,
a person or suspect
might refuse to respond to an order
from a law enforcement official
who doesn't clearly identify themselves.
There's also the danger
that various law enforcement officers
might not be able to recognize each other,
especially since many different military
and police groups are involved
in both DC and Portland.
And riot helmets often
have identifying numbers
on their backs, partly for this reason.
But the big reason, obviously,
is that if officers don't
identify themselves,
then they can't be held
accountable for their misbehavior.
This is especially egregious
because the protests
are directly calling for
police accountability.
Anonymity might be a good thing in war,
but it's very bad when the officers
are controlling demonstrations
in their own country.
And the precise legal question
of whether it's reasonable
for an officer to refuse to
identify him or herself by name
and state who he works for
has not really been decided
by federal courts.
Obviously, when officers are undercover,
it would be reasonable for
them to remain anonymous.
But in situations like a protest,
it's vitally important for people to know
that they're being stopped by police
instead of by civilians.
And courts have generally
held that officers
should identify themselves
in these situations,
but it's still a novel legal issue,
at least from a federal standpoint.
There's no federal law that requires
federal law enforcement
officers to wear a name tag,
to wear a specific identifiable number
that can be attributed to
the individual officer,
in part probably because
federal law enforcement
has been very, very curtailed
in where it can be used in the US
and it's really very recently
that they are expanding
outside of their clear mandate.
But just because there's no
federal law that applies here
doesn't mean that state
law doesn't control.
And while there is no federal
law requiring federal officers
to wear insignia identifying themselves
or individual name tags,
Oregon law does require any
law enforcement officers
purporting to enforce state law
to conspicuously display an
official identification card
showing the officer's lawful authority.
Oregon authorizes federal
officers to enforce state law,
but only under specific circumstances.
A federal officer may arrest someone
for a crime committed in
the officer's presence
if the person has probable cause.
Under Oregon's authorization
of federal law enforcement officers,
a federal officer may arrest someone
for a crime committed in
the officer's presence,
if the person has probable cause,
the officer informs the
person to be arrested
of the officer's authority
and reason for the arrest,
and that the officer
takes the arrested person
to a peace officer or
magistrate without delay.
And there's one other legal requirement.
The federal officer cannot make arrests
for state criminal violations
unless they receive Oregon training
and are certified by the state.
This tells us some important things.
First, a federal CBP
officer could arrest someone
for a violation of Oregon state law,
but only if they have probable cause.
Second, the arrest is only legal
if the officer tells the person
the basis for their authority,
who they are and who they work for.
And third, the federal officer
must swiftly bring that person
before a judge or magistrate
so they're notified about
their charges and rights.
And fourth, the federal
officer must be certified
by the state of Oregon to
make arrests pursuant to law,
which takes us to the first
of many lawsuits here.
Based on what we know,
it doesn't seem like the
federal officers in Portland
can prove that they meet one
or any of these conditions.
Oregon Governor Kate Brown
and Portland Mayor Ted Wheeler
have implored DHS to remove CBP
and other federal officers from the state.
The Oregon Department of
Justice has filed a lawsuit
accusing DHS and others agencies
of unlawful law enforcement.
In addition to CBP, the
state has identified
other active law enforcement agencies
as the US Marshals Service
and the Federal Protective Service.
The failure of federal
officers to identify themselves
is actually one of the
reasons for this lawsuit.
The complaint names 10
John Doe defendants,
who are just placeholders
that you put in a lawsuit complaint
until you know the actual
identity of that person,
and names the 10 Doe defendants who,
"have made it impossible
"for them to be individually identified
"by carrying out law enforcement actions
"without wearing any
identifying information,
"even so much as the
agency that employs them."
The lawsuit seeks a
temporary restraining order
to prevent federal authorities
from unlawfully detaining
Oregon residents like Mark Pettibone.
According to the suit,
"Oregonians have the right
"to walk through downtown
Portland at night
"and in the early hours of the morning.
"Ordinarily, a person exercising his right
"to walk through the streets of Portland
"who is confronted by anonymous men
"in military-type fatigues and
ordered into an unmarked van
"can reasonably assume
that he's being kidnapped
"and is the victim of a crime."
This suit alleges that this is
an unreasonable search and seizure
in violation of the Fourth Amendment
which will be repeated
if the federal government
is not enjoined from its activities.
The complaint alleges that this activity
of federal law enforcement officers
violate Oregon citizens' First
Amendment right to protest,
since, "Citizens who are reasonably afraid
"of being picked up and
shoved into unmarked vans,
"possibly by federal officers,
"possibly by individuals
opposed to protests,
"will feel compelled to stay away
"for their own personal safety
"and will therefore be
unable to express themselves
"in the way that they have a right to do."
The state attorney general alleges
that the federal government did not notify
or coordinate with state officers.
Essentially, the state is saying
that the federal government
just showed up to the protests
without any requests from
state or local authorities
or training by the state.
The ACLU of Oregon has
also filed a lawsuit
against the Department
of Homeland Security
and the US Marshals Service.
The ACLU's lawsuit seeks to
block federal law enforcement
from dispersing, arresting,
threatening to arrest,
or using physical force
against journalists
or legal observers.
The plaintiffs in that case
include the newspaper the Portland Mercury
and individual journalists
and legal observers
who say that they were attacked
by federal law enforcement.
The ACLU is planning several lawsuits
on behalf of protesters
who say that their rights were violated,
so this may be the tip of the iceberg.
So, is this a constitutional crisis
of the federal government
against the states?
Well, Governor Brown has told
federal officers to get out
and President Trump said no.
The federal government
has officially refused
the state's request to withdraw
federal law enforcement
from the state.
The state can argue that
it has certain powers
reserved to it by the 10th Amendment.
And while there's a real difficulty
balancing governmental
response to domestic crises,
the states generally have
flexibility and authority
to respond as they see the
needs of their citizens.
And at the same time,
the federal government also has a right
to respond to federal crises.
The video that I did a few
weeks back on posse comitatus
and the Insurrection Act laid
out some of these issues.
The founders were afraid of
concentrating too much power
in the presidency or
the federal government.
And one of the checks on
the tyrannical government
was to give states the power
to overrule the federal government
during certain conflicts.
And a lot of the power
that we assume the federal government has
might have been reserved for states
because of the 10th Amendment.
However, the Trump
Administration can counter
and say that it's merely
protecting federal property
and that the CBP is legally permitted
to help Federal Protective Service
protect federal buildings.
And that might effectively
give the president
a big personal army
of more than 60,000
employees and officers.
And while in the abstract this
might not be the worst thing,
of course the federal government
needs law enforcement officers
to enforce federal laws,
unfortunately, we're
seeing a pattern here.
As we've learned over
the past three months,
the Trump Administration will meet
vandalism and property damage
with an overwhelming show
of paramilitary force
against American citizens.
And in DC, effectively,
Bill Barr, attorney
general, was in charge,
but here it's the acting director
of Department of Homeland
Security Chad Wolf,
who has been confirmed by the Senate.
I don't need invitations by the state,
state mayors or state
governors to do our job.
We're gonna do that whether
they like us there or not.
- And his acting deputy, Ken Cuccinelli,
who's also the acting director
of Citizenship and
Immigration Services, CIS,
has also not been confirmed by the Senate.
And a federal court ruled that Cuccinelli
was not lawfully
appointed to his position,
and therefore he lacked authority
to issue several directives
pertaining to immigration,
but he's still on the job.
And in fact, he has two jobs.
Moreover, Mark Morgan, the
acting director of CBP,
also has not been confirmed by the Senate
and neither has Matthew
Albence, the acting head of ICE,
or his acting deputy, Derek Benner.
And of course, the pattern
of a mouse wanting a cookie
and a glass of milk continues.
Lawfare reports that an internal DHS memo
authorizes intelligence
collection of Americans
in order to protect statues and memorials.
The Department of Homeland Security
says that their Intelligence
and Analysis Office
is "collecting and reporting
on various activities
"in the context of elevated threats
"targeting monuments,
memorials, and statues,"
and it gives legal guidance concerning
the "expanded intelligence
activities necessary
"to mitigate the significant
threat to homeland security
"posed by such activities."
Again, we're talking about statues here.
The intelligence collection
is authorized to prevent,
"damage sufficient to impede the purpose
"or function of monuments."
If you know how to impede
the purpose or function
of a monument or a statue,
please tell me in the comments. (laughing)
And of course, the
pattern continues again.
DHS is apparently making plans
to send over 150 agents to Chicago
for unknown reasons
under unknown authority.
This is obviously a very worrying trend,
but thankfully there are
brave souls out there
willing to legally observe these protests
and tell us what is happening.
Thanks to them, we have video
of what happened to
Christopher David in Portland,
who stood in front of the
federal law enforcement officers
and asked them about the oath
that they took to the Constitution
while they pummeled him and
broke two bones in his hand
and he just stood there
like a friggin' tree.
And if you go out in the
protest like Christopher David
and the person that recorded
what happened to him
and want to put together
the best videos you can,
you should take Penny
Lane's Skillshare class
Filmmaking from Home:
Turn Found Footage into
a Compelling Video.
Ah, 2020, where even the
segues are incredibly dark.
Penny's class will help
you take your footage
and turn it into a compelling video,
like how the federal
government is usurping states
and turning cities into
occupied paramilitary zones.
Penny developed a unique
approach to storytelling
that transforms existing content,
from historical archives
to YouTube videos,
into innovative or irreverent films.
Skillshare, as you know, is
an online learning community
that has tens of thousands
of classes on everything,
like music, design,
technology, and business.
Now, a yearly membership
is less than $10 per month,
but the first 1,000 LegalEagles
will get two free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited
access to must-know topics
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things,
all free for two months.
Just click on the link below
to get two free months of Skillshare.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that there should be limits
on federal law enforcement
being used in the states?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
Real Law Reviews over here,
where I talk about all of
the legal issues in the day
and all the crazy things that
are happening in our cities.
So, click on this link,
and I'll see you in court.